Now this next question is kind of long and I didn't talk to this person on the phone about this,
but I wanted to put this up there because I wanted to actually commit to the doctor
and you'll see why when I want to answer this. So I talked to this person on the phone and then they
sent me what their doctors assessed what the plan was and I was impressed because we could tell you.
You wanted to get that. I went back on a Fedman pulse of four days, three days off, two weeks ago,
total of eight days. And my liver enzymes blew up. My ALT went from 19 to 149 and my ST went from
20 to 115. Treatment team wanted to give me tests and cortisone medication to counter
a possible side effect for my chemo or immunotherapy. I came clean and told them that I started taking
Fedman. We all agreed to retest and see if my numbers go down by the end of the week,
which would be about five days off Fedman. I also go back to Mayo next week for
additional MRI CT scan and lab with chemotherapy and immunotherapy to resume on 12-18 or 19.
I've also stopped the methylene blue, the low-nose male truxode. Should I adjust any of the supplements
that have been prescribed to help lower the liver numbers? I was instructed to stop taking
tuncom because it can conflict with the chemo and immunotherapy regimen of us.
So I got this after we spoke and this person sent me their labs and I sent them an email that they
should just stop the Fedman because that's what I thought right off the bat that was causing the
ST and ALT. Remember, we've spoken before about this phenomena. Many times a drug interaction with
your liver will raise, will elevate ALT and AST but will spare alcohol and phosphatase.
If we have a metastasis to the liver or metastasis to the bone,
how you could help differential diagnosis that with a blood test is that if there's metastasis to
the liver, you'll have elevated ALT, AST and alcohol and phosphatase and milli-roomed usually.
If it's metastasis to the bone, you'll have elevated alcohol and phosphatase,
no elevation of milli-roomed, no elevation of ALT, no elevation of AST,
it's also possibly an elevation of calcium. So you're trying to differential diagnosis so it's
looked at that blood test and it made most sense to me that it was a drug interaction
and this person was unfedmented. We know we've said this dozens of times already. If you're unfedbed,
50% of the people don't detoxify it well, it affects their liver. How is it going to affect
their liver? It could adjust their liver and it will elevate ALT, AST. That's what I thought right off.
The band I told this person to stop the fedment and immediately when this person told their doctor,
their doctor went right to that too and I just wanted to say we just need more doctors like this
because this is the first time that I've heard. The oncologists in the medical field say the same
thing which I'm really happy. So they said stage 4, low endocards available with
brain metastasis. The plan was to stay on these medications.
Brain or adiacea was completed in September, planning to follow up with a male suspect.
This could be related to the ingestion of fedendizol which is proven to cause liver toxicity.
So I was really glad to see that. You guys, you have to be aware that if you're unfedbed
as all, it can be toxic to your liver if you don't detoxify it. Like I said, about 50% of the
people don't detoxify it well. The only way you're going to know you're not going to necessarily have
any symptoms. This person probably didn't have liver pain but the subjective sign of that is
going to be elevation of ALT and AST. And the only way you're going to know that is to get a blood
test. That's why you are promised to me if you're going to go on fed bed, you're going to get regular
blood tests. And what you would get is a comprehensive metabolic panel. Comprehensive metabolic panel.
If you just went and got a basic metabolic panel, it doesn't include AST and ALT. So you have to ask
for a comprehensive metabolic panel. You can get just what's called a liver panel too. It doesn't have
the other things in it but it's best to get a comprehensive metabolic panel because then you could
differential diagnose with the elevated or not elevated calcium. So it's what it is. Use that as
another teaching tool.